[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 11th of
January I'm Katie blls the spectator's
political editor and your host this week
coming up on the
show can anything stop Donald Trump
that's what our deputy editor Freddy
gray writes about to the cover piece
this week we'll take a look at why Trump
keeps winning and the religious right
who wants to vote for him over in Europe
popularism has also shifted to the right
with leaders like Georgia Maloney G wers
and Marine Leen growing in popularity is
this all about immigration is it Net
Zero and what does this mean for the
future of the EU our chairman Andrew
Neil and the writer Christopher Coldwell
join me to discuss the Scottish national
party have put forward a bill to ban
conversion therapy for people going
through gender
dysmorphia could the law lead to the
wrong people getting locked up spectator
writer Debbie Hatton and legal expert
Michael fan join me on the
show and finally what is the secret here
long and happy relationship for the
magazine The Spectators producer Natasha
fose who was producing this week's
episode has written about one couple who
thinks a contract is the answer Simone
and Malcolm Collins authors of the book
a prag IST guide to relationships are
convincing couples to iron out any
issues in a relationship Manifesto could
it be the answer they join me on the
show before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV do subscribe to our YouTube
channel just click the Subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
Bell icon so you never miss an episode I
should also say that the spectator
broadcast team is hiring if you think
you could produce the show perhaps do it
better or produce any of our podcasts
and why not apply our applications
window is open until the 21st of January
and the link will be in the bio of this
video join
us first up for the cover piece this
week Freddy gray has written about
Donald Trump's Second Coming based with
91 Fel counts and fierce political
opposition the former president keeps
going and it looks like he might keep
winning is he Invincible Freddy joins me
now to
discuss Freddy thank you for joining
spectator TV this week and on your
birthday yeah it is my birthday do you
want to tell view how old you are uh yes
I do a lot uh I'm 44 today now in the
magazine this week you writee about
Donald Trump's bid now there's still
various stages to go through he's not
yet the Republican candidate but you say
that's pretty nailed on at this point I
think so I mean I think it's quite fun
for journalists uh and pundits and
analysts to say that uh you know Ronda
sanz's ground game in Iowa is really
good he could win Iowa next week Nikki
Haley starting to look a bit of a threat
in New Hampshire and New Hampshire which
is the week after Iowa uh is famously
this Open primary where anyone can vote
pretty much anyone can register to vote
um so therefore Independence can could
sway it for Nikki Haley I think there's
there is a little bit of Truth in all
that but really it's grasping at straws
because the boring reality is Donald
Trump is miles ahead and unless the
polls are monumentally wrong uh he's
going to be the nominee um and really
the race is just a coronation
process in which case uh the argument
you make in your piece is the bit that's
far more uncertain is the next stage
which is the legal rules around whether
Donald Trump can stand or not now we
talked previously on this podcast about
lawfare can you just update viewers of
where we are exactly when it comes to
Donald Trump and uh the barriers he has
to get free to be able to stand well uh
yesterday Donald Trump was in court in
Washington DC uh and he didn't have to
be there but very interestingly he chose
to be there rather than in Iowa
campaigning um and I'll get on to why
why I think that's interesting next but
just as far as his case is concerned
this is just one of his indictments so
this is the January 6th Federal
indictment uh which is that he he didn't
the charge importantly isn't that he
incited an Insurrection it's that he uh
among other things defrauded the United
States stes or conspired to defraud the
United
States Donald Trump claims that
presidential immunity the fact that he
was president means that he should not
be charged with the with these crimes um
and so his lawyers were making that case
in DC and it sounded very much yesterday
as though the judges were quite
skeptical about Trump's lawyers claims
of presidential immunity so it looks as
though he'll be rejected and he will go
ahead to court on that indictment in
March the reason I think it's
interesting that Trump chose chose to be
there rather than in Iowa campaigning or
anywhere else um is because it shows
that Trump knows how good the
indictments are for him or he believes
they are good for him and so far he's
he's been right uh every single
indictment produced uh a further rise in
his polling the mugshot uh the famous
mug shot in August of him in in Fulton
County jail house um that is if you look
at sort of the the chart of his polling
from that moment it's just gone up and
up and up and up so Trump has it's it's
a a risk because of the way it plays out
in the National but certainly among
Republicans Trump knows that these
trials mean that the race is over
because everybody's talking about Trump
they don't care about Ronda santis they
don't particularly care about Nikki
Haley and do you think one of the other
thing that's benefited him is clearly
this is a lot of publicity and this
sense that he is being stopped and
people are not having a right to have
their say um but you also have the fact
that because he is prolific because he
was previously president it's almost say
you've had an incumbent in a way that
doesn't usually happen uh you know when
you're picking your candidate for one of
these yes I mean I think the incumbency
factor is very strong I mean the the
Republican machine is his to a certain
extent uh Republican politicians and
local activists and so on if they want
to get on in the party if they want to
succeed if they're ambitious uh they
probably have to be very careful not to
say anything bad about Donald Trump
publicly so he has a a kind of strangled
over over the Republican party and he
has for a long time uh that makes him a
very different to your usual candidate
it makes him very different to the
candidate he was in
2016 um he's he's he's hard to beat if
not impossible to beat as far as the
Republican side is concerned now there
are different indictments as you
mentioned different legal challenges for
Donald Trump uh you know some states
where he's not even being put on the
ballot at the moment what do you think
are the most serious in terms of
stopping his roote to getting there uh I
mean I think the most s dramatic terms
of you know the on the not just the
legal side but the public side will be
the January 6th ST which is why Joe
Biden's been talking about it this uh
week Joe Biden went to Valley Forge in
Pennsylvania and did a big speech to
Mark uh the third anniversary of January
the 6th um I think that one is the big
one I think uh if he goes down for that
but the the point is you know the way
Democrats talk about him they talk about
him like he's Al Capone so it doesn't
really matter which one they get him on
whether it's you know some complicated
tax thing that just get and put in jail
or thrown away or just convicted or
found guilty in
court uh they talk about him as though
he's such a monster that it doesn't
matter what they get him they just got
to get him and what about the idea that
he could run from a jail cell and then
pardon himself well he could do it and
you know Eugene Debs has run ran for
presid socialist uh ran for president
before and got about a million votes
which was pretty surprising for a
socialist in America
um there is obviously if he's in jail
it's just very impossible to imagine
what uh that will be like what whether
he will continue to run I imagine he
probably would uh whether Americans will
still uh find the willingness to vote
for him I think probably not is the
answer but then you do have to remember
that Americans have a very different
understanding of the legal system the
British people do I think when we talk
when Brits talk to Americans about this
a bit of a things get lost in trans
ation um because the American political
system legal system is very obviously
politicized uh and everybody knows it
and so there's a sort of contempt for it
that you don't have in Britain now one
of the interesting things you writee
about is evangelicals and the fact that
this vote base seems to be moving
towards Donald Trump which is surprising
given they weren't usually associated
with him so what do you think is there a
law of Donald Trump 2.0 when it comes to
this uh well white evangelicals uh love
Trump uh he got 80% of their support in
2016 I think he got slightly more in
2020 and what's interesting is that
these are not uh the evangelicals of
their parents' generation they don't go
to church as much uh and yet they
identify with Trump in an almost
religious way I think there's been a lot
of rubbish spoken about this but there's
some very interesting research by Pew
which shows that people identify as
Evangelical now because they support
Trump uh which means that he's actually
a sort of Baptist figure in some ways
for the American right um and that
politics has become the master identity
as some Professor told the New York
Times this week in that people identify
politically as somebody who supports
Trump and then they decide that they're
an Evangelical and that's a major shift
in America and Trump has really been
able to capitalize on that and I think
people underestimate uh the extent to
which his the sense of him as a sort of
spiritual Warrior
is actually quite alive and real for a
lot of Americans I mean you just have to
look online and obviously you know
there's always crazy stuff online but
it's it's a significant thing that a lot
of people think of trump as some sort of
divinely ordained figure uh who has come
to restore America to Greatness um that
sounds crazy to us I know uh but a lot
of people believe it and even if you
don't believe it as as I try to say in
the pce the Church of trump is quite
broad you don't really have to believe
that he's divinely appointed but you can
say actually look at the Democrats what
are they doing with the G with the legal
system why are they persecuting him like
this to start thinking that you know
maybe there's something very unique
about him uh and that I think explains
his appeal and now we talked about
things that were uncertain on so of
course how how this lawfare works what
will happen in the courts and the other
question is who will his running partner
be um now we're starting to see uh
several I think female politicians
thanks to comments uh Donald Trump and
those close to have made suggesting he
might go for a female running partner
this time around trying to almost
position themselves who are the runners
and Riders well I I like that Donald
Trump said he likes the concept of a
woman uh being his vice president we've
read we read a lot into that uh so yes
there are various women are seem to be
competing uh Carrie lake is putting
herself front and center she's doing a
lot of uh greasing up to Trump World I
think she's going to do a big speech
next week uh she is a uh a television
presenter turned uh governor candidate
who actually failed but like Donald
Trump um complained about the result uh
and then there is um of course uh Nikki
Haley who everybody thinks Trump might
do what he did in 2016 which he
surprised people by picking a sort of
establishment choice and people think
that he might do that with Nikki Haley
they actually have quite a good
relationship Nikki Haley and Donald
Trump uh and that's possible although
Trump World is far more radical now and
Donald Trump Jr promised uh crowds of
his adoring uh Trump fans that he will
not let his father appoint Nikki Haley
um and so that leaves Elise stepanick
who uh is also mentioned in D's piece uh
and there are other people like some
people think he might choose tulsy
gabbard who a sort of Maverick Democrat
who now presents occasionally on Fox
News um so there are various uh women
Runners and Riders uh I think the thing
with Trump is he likes to keep everybody
guessing and he sees it as this is the
closest uh that it gets to uh reality TV
that it gets to The Apprentice the show
that he really loved doing um possibly
more than anything else so he loves that
element of I'm you know he's the
bachelor he gets to choose who he who he
wants to dance with and just finally if
we do see Trump uh obviously be selected
get to a point where he is not in a Cell
he is out their campaigning what do you
think the current I suppose perception
of your average voter in America of
Donald Trump is not the you know
hardcore Republicans that get to pick
the candidates um you how is all this
looking to them well I think the thing
to remember about Americans and Trump is
that so many people love Donald Trump
intensely so many people hate Donald
Trump intensely there is a large number
of Americans who don't feel very
strongly about Donald Trump and I think
it's those people who will decide the
election um they probably don't like him
very much as a person but then they're
going to look at the economy and think
you know was it better then than it is
now and they may well say yes so
obviously in such a huge country you
have enormously differing views of
Donald Trump I think the thing to
remember is that if you speak to most
Americans uh they won't be as passionate
about Donald Trump as probably the
people you see in the media thank you
Freddy and happy birthday thank you
Katie that was my best birthday present
I could have ever ever asked for could
2024 be remembered for Europe's populist
Revolution journalist Christopher
Coldwell writes about this for the
magazine this week we've seen this
anti-immigration nationalist Trend in
Italy the Netherlands Sweden and Poland
so who could be next and what does it
mean for the European Parliament
elections in June joining me to discuss
is Andrew Neil and Christopher
Coldwell Christopher Andrew thank you
for joining spectator TV today
Christopher you write in the magaz this
week uh that you challenge the idea that
popularism has peaked what is your
evidence for
this well um some of it's in elections
uh some of it's in
polling um if you look at France uh uh
Marine Le Pen is the leading candidate
if the you know if the would be the
leading candidate if the uh presidential
elections were were held today um her
party is at the top of the polls in in
the European elections which are going
to take place in in June she's someone
who's not just on the right but is on
what used to be called the extreme right
in in in France and which has
increasingly supplanted the old um
Republican party in France the old gist
party in Germany there are three state
elections this year now they're all in
the East so they're kind of special but
the um
the alternative for Germany which is the
rightmost party in in Germany is leading
all of them gett Builders just to
everyone's shock in Holland just
finished at the top of the polls uh in
their lower house elections there's a
little bit of contrary evidence
including the Polish election last
October where Donald tusk's Civic
platform won but in general it's really
we appear to be in the middle of quite a
wave and andreww do you agree with that
when it comes to who the key players are
who are driving this shift to the right
yes I think Christopher's article in
this week spectator is full of sound
Common Sense the the death of right-wing
populism in Europe is often predicted it
reminds me of The Economist magazine and
Africa every now and then The Economist
magazine finds a a success story in
Africa and it writes it up and says this
is the new Africa it's a wonderful new
beginning and within 3 weeks of that
article being published there's a
military coup and there's cares and
despair everywhere and I think the look
The populist right is not going to
overrun Europe it's not going to run
Europe but it's not played out yet it is
going to get stronger before it gets
weaker and of course in Madame Maloney
in Italy you've already got a prime
minister from the populist right though
interestingly she has turned out to be
not as quite popular right as her party
which is is very right Chris's quite
right about France I've just flown in
from France uh this morning uh to do
this and nobody uh expects uh macron's
party to come first in the European
election parliamentary elections this
June everybody expects often through
gritty teeth that Madame leen's party
will be the biggest french party in the
European Parliament so uh he got a long
way to go yet and I think think it's
dangerous if the European Elites the
more mainstream Elites don't realize
this is happening and they can just
shrug it off and Christopher Andrew
mentions macron of course macron
actually did team up with the pen
recently when it came to his plans on
immigration because he needed the
support how much of this do you think is
being driven on the continent by
concerns over immigration do you think
that is the main push it's a very
interesting thing because
immigration is really not at its peak
now either in the short term or in the
broad picture of things we're in the
winter now there are a fewer boats
coming across from um from Africa and
we're not even really having a major
push the way we did in 2015 but
everyone's thinking about it and it's
kind of interesting that in France in
November there was a stabbing in uh in
the Drome which is down in Southeastern
France sort of near
groby uh the kids who did the stabbing
were were all French but they were of
Migrant background and there was
something about the incident that really
got people hyped up about migration the
issue is big I think there's no question
about it and Andrew what do you think do
you think there is a factor here about
incumbents um if you look all around the
world you know beyond uh Europe it does
feel as though in a time of high
interest rates cost of living incumbent
governments are really under pressure
and perhaps that is uh you know one of
the reasons that you're now seeing those
on the right often those viers Outsiders
uh you know getting the support and
coming back in I think when you've had
uh inflation quite High inflation
highest for a generation unexpected
inflation inflation that the central
banks told us would be transitory I
think when you get that coupled with a
cost of living uh crisis then throw the
bastards out is a pretty strong uh
election cry time for a change so I
certainly think it's a difficult time
for incumbents as uh Mr sunak will no
doubt find out this year and indeed Mr
Biden is uh finding it out in rather
difficult ways in the United States Mr
macron in some trouble too changing his
prime minister to try and revamp his
government the Schultz Coalition in
Germany going nor nowhere Treading Water
I'm more concerned though that this rise
on in right-wing populism is really
serious and bad news for Europe and it's
not for the normal reasons uh people
tend to talk about right-wing populace
is just they're a bit more right-wing
than the mainstream right but that's not
the way to see it they stand for things
entirely different than the mainstream
right now you look at Europe which in my
is a continent in real trouble and a
continent in serious decline the
European Union's economy uh even without
Britain used to be the same size as the
United States now it's a fraction of the
United States Europe is an economic
decline it has a ranous Russia uh
already causing Mayhem in the Ukraine
and who knows if it is allowed to win
there where it will go from there at
heart in Europe Europe you have a
problem of governments are too big
taxation is too high and regulation is
omnipresent so let's just take the
economic circumstances of Europe at the
moment and the problem with Russia and
Mr Putin what do the right-wing populist
bring to that well first of all they're
big government people they ain't Ronald
Reagan or Margaret Thatcher they believe
in big government indeed if you take
Madame Leen and France her economic
policies are not that different from Mr
meenon uh who is the Jeremy Corbin of
France they believe in big government
they believe in government intervention
they believe in government control of
Industry they believe in protectionism
they do not believe in markets or
Jeffersonian type limited government or
taxation so that doesn't help Europe to
move down that road and then you take
the second thing you would sometimes
think as was the case in the old days in
America where it was say Ronald Reagan
versus Jerry Ford two Republicans Reagan
was the more rightwing and therefore the
more hard line against Russia in the
Cold War that's not true with this
populist right they like President Putin
they've got a soft spot for the Kremlin
they repeat Kremlin talking points uh
when they appear look at Mrs Maloney's
party although she has not gone down
that road Madame Leen had one of her
election campaigns bankrolled by Pro
Putin Banks so if you take the two big
threats that Europe faces one Russia the
second a declining economy a sclerotic
economy the populace right can only make
them
worse Christopher do you agree with that
um with parts of it I do think that uh
that this right in in a lot of places is
a is a different right than what we used
to call the right that's because it
represents a uh a different class well
there's a couple of things it represents
a different class it it's not a it's not
a um an upper middle class right it is a
um it's a collection of people who
feel um let's say excluded from the uh
from the world they once uh they once
knew so for instance to take the the the
national front they've done very well in
uh neighborhoods that used to be
communist um in France there's also a a
sort of a
historical difference I think Germany
has had a really good last 20 years but
none of these none of these Continental
countries really had the experience of a
uh of let's say a free market boom um
the way the United States and the UK did
under uh Reagan and Thatcher um
respectively so there's not there's not
quite the same push for um for an
unshackling of entrepreneurship on the
continent there the way there would be
in more anglophone cultures but it comes
to some of these elections coming up and
the rise of the parties which do you
think could have the most profound
effect do you think it is perhaps the
pen uh gaining a tendency because of
that uh you know Putin tendency or
ultimately is the big deciding factor
going to be actually what what happens
in America um because uh so much of our
foreign policy comes from America well I
think the the election to keep an eye on
in Europe for uh the state of things to
come or the shape of things to come is
it for the European Parliament now of
course the European Parliament is of no
geopolitical significance whatsoever but
it does tell you how Europeans are
thinking and I expect the popul right
block made up of parties from not just
France but from Germany and Italy and
many other even some Scandinavian
countries I suspect that could end up
being the biggest Block in the European
Parliament uh the French president
presal elections not till 2027 so we've
got a while to wait there and so far afd
in Germany as chrisop says and his
excellent peace is is strong in a
particular region which is the old East
Germany uh there so I and I don't think
in this America what America is doing
America often has incredible influence
in European elections especially in
British elections because what happens
in America tends to end up over here at
some stage perhaps in a different shapee
or form but it originates from the
United States I don't think Europe needs
that now Europe's at a different part in
its economic cycle could be that Trump
if he is reelected will reinforce the uh
uh European populist right but I think
they're on their own their their own
trajectory uh here I think that
immigration will probably start ramping
up again that'll be a further Prospect
for say the Sweden Democrats not the
social Democrats they're very different
the Sweden Democrats are right-wing
populist we've already heard from what's
been happening in Holland I remember
there was a Danish uh right-wing
populist many years ago whose defense
policy was to put uh loud speakers up on
the Danish border and Shout we surrender
in Russian that was his defense policy
so I think we're in for a dangerous uh
time here and I think it's broad broadly
based as Christopher mentioned Poland
has bucked the trend for the moment but
that may not be forever uh that may
quite be rolled back quite quickly in
fact and and I don't know where this is
taking us because we now have a
continent bereft of leadership Britain
has gone from the EU and can't provide
It the French and the Germans don't even
get on anymore the the motor of the EU
which was the Franco German Alliance
that's gone mackan and Schulz barely
talk to each other they don't like each
other uh where Italy can't do it Spain
can't do it I mean the the rising power
in Europe is of course Poland and that's
now a formidable uh military power but
where will the leadership come in Europe
particularly if Mr Trump does come back
and and hits us with a double whammy he
forces zalinski to settle in Ukraine
giving away a huge chunk of his country
and he begins to undermine NATO I mean
that is Crisis with a Capital C
and I think the rise of the popul right
will will make that crisis even worse
Christopher Andrew just set out why it's
quite hard to see who would take on that
leadership role um do you think any of
the current uh leaders or politicians
rising up the ranks would be able to uh
you know I I just I've been struck being
in Poland um as Andrew says by what a
what a serious country it's becoming and
it's not just it's not just militarily
but every time time I go there it feels
richer and more energetic and the um I
understand that it's been under
unfortunate circumstances but the influx
of a of of a couple million more
ukrainians has really given a lot of
dynamism to that economy it's created
some problems too it's driven driven up
housing costs but it it's it's given
them a way to keep a productive economy
without uh without inflation I think
that the United States has generally
been more engaged with Europe um when
it's had a Democratic president in power
at least that's been the case this
Century Trump was pretty hands off of
Europe last time I also think that that
for all his rhetorical Bluster about
NATO paying its way um that's really a
logistical complaint it's a complaint
about about budgeting as far as his view
of the world his view of the world on
everything is kind of locked in the in
in the 1960s and therefore he he might
see Europe as relatively more important
than a than a neutral analyst would on
the uh on the world stage so I think
it's there's there's a lot of unknowns
in this and they won't all necessarily
cut against uh Europe and Andrew I
suppose looking at Trump in the us but
as Christopher sets out in his piece the
rise of populists across the continent
is there a certain irony that in Britain
after brex that we seem to be heading to
kir starma well he's no one's idea of a
populist I'll give you that um we do
seem to be bucking the trend a little
bit uh of course that's partly an
incumbency story and against in a sense
Britain had its populist uh Splurge by
voting for brexit in
2016 and and I think even if you were a
brexit supporter um people are pretty
disillusioned with the outcome so far
that look there's a long while to go
we're not going back into the European
Union in the foreseeable future but that
last exercise in in in populism didn't
work out I think a lot of the people who
voted brexit feel betrayed and they're
they're disillusioned I agree with
Christopher the Mr Trump is very hard to
read sometimes he can't even read
himself uh I remember
saying to him in 2015 at maral Lago in
fact that uh was he going to run for
president because he had no chance of
winning and uh which was of much I know
about American politics to which Mr
Trump said no I know I won't so he
doesn't know himself sometimes about
what's going on but he did think he
would put his speaking fees up Trump is
unpredictable in a way that's not great
either the one thing allies need is a
certain certainty and a reliability that
you can count uh uh on your major Ally
uh Christopher is right that uh
Democrats have often been the best
democratic presidents have often been
the best allies of Europe JFK of course
we think we think of but of course
Ronald Reagan was an incredible Ally of
Europe and he basically won the Cold War
uh for for Europe so uh my problem these
days is as I look on both sides of the
Atlantic I see neither a JFK nor a
Ronald
rean and because for a final question to
you um as I suppose uh you think about
some of those more Centrist politicians
who feel that perhaps they're going out
of fashion we talked about immigration
as one of the the big pressures there's
also uh we mentioned the afd earlier um
Net Zero the move against it um do you
think that is one of the things which is
seeing uh voters move more to those on
the right who are challenging it oh
absolutely and I I think the real
beginning of that was the Gile Jon which
was a real threat to macron's presidency
altogether just this past spring
remember the um the Dutch Farmers rose
up against the the Ruta government and
this very week we have a huge Farmers
strike in Germany two groups that are re
really feel threatened by Net Zero it's
it's it's the farmers and the people who
are dependent on cars it's not that
they're climate deniers or they object
to fighting global warming they just
object to the way the costs of it have
been distributed Christopher is
absolutely right if you want to give the
populist right a leg up just continue
with Net Zero let's of a bunch of upper
middle class people forcing all the
costs of Net Zero onto Ordinary
workingclass People it's sheer Genius if
you want to stir up the right thank you
Andrew thank you
Christopher next the Scottish national
party have proposed new laws to ban
conversion practices for people with
gender dysphoria spectator writer Debbie
Hatton has written on why this is a
Sinister bill which could end up
criminalizing the wrong people she joins
me now along with legal expert Michael
fan thank you for joining spectator TV
Debbie this week you write about the
Scottish government's planned ban on
conversion therapy and how it is perhaps
more Sinister than it first seems on
paper can you tell us more well you've
got to ask why the Scottish government
is so keen on pushing this legislation
and pushing it now if you read through
the consultation it their own
consultation it's clear that uh there is
little need for any new laws uh coercive
and abusive practices are already
illegal and they struggle to actually
find any examples of where this law will
actually catch things that that the
other law wouldn't so you got ask why
they're doing it and the uh the concern
the whole time is that it will
criminalize normal exploratory therapy
so that uh so that therapists cannot
challenge patients on what they say
about themselves and most worryingly of
all in my view when children are
involved therapists may be in a position
where they're unable to do anything
apart from blindly affirm what the child
tells them yes and Debbie in your
article you give an example of
potentially someone going around speak
to a friend who's who's thinking about
uh transitioning and how they could fall
fou of this can can you talk us through
the example you
offer well it's just not clear what he's
going to what he's going to be
criminalized and is's not what he's not
uh the consultation talks about
safeguards but uh we're talking about uh
pushing the uh criminality further than
what it is at the moment so at the
moment it's a criminal offense to try to
uh con change somebody's sexual
orientation uh if you mean them harm and
that should surely be enough so to push
that further suggests to me that the the
the Scottish government is looking at uh
is looking at those normal conversations
where people don't mean anybody any harm
they just want to try and help Michael
can you talk us through the Practical
implications of what's being proposed so
the The Proposal that they have here is
um is quite extensive there's a lot that
they're that they're trying to do and
simultaneously there's a lot that
they're expressly saying that they're
not trying to do um so Debbie has
mentioned that the um there's a lot of
this that's already covered by um
existing criminal laws a lot of things
that we would ordinarily understand when
we think of the phrase kind of
conversion therapy that would just be
already covered under the law relating
to assault or um kind of anything that
relates to kind of a physical um attack
on on an individual so what they're
trying to capture here is thought
talking to people um and trying to
convince people in the process of
talking with them uh to change or to
suppress their sexual orientation or
their gender identity or their own
perception of their sexual orientation
or their um gender identity
but there's a car out in the proposal to
um ensure that if you're engaging this
from the perspective of a healthcare
provider um that's not going to be um
captured by the proposal so it seems
like the only people who are actually
going to be captured by this proposal um
the most likely people are going to be
people like family members or friends of
individuals who are talking to them and
are going beyond what you would
ordinarily kind of describe as just kind
of exploring someone's identity but for
example let's say you have a a mother of
a of a teenager and the um the teenager
is a biological female um who has in the
past expressed um same-sex attraction
and is now identifying as a boy now if
the parent had responded to that child
and said no look you're not you're not a
a heterosexual boy you're probably
dealing with some kind of internalized
homophobia you likely are just a lesbian
and we love you when we um are happy to
to um affirm that well that could become
a criminal offense now uh because what's
happening there is that the the parent
is um is purposly trying to um engage in
a conversation that is challenging the
individual self assessment of their own
identity that's the most likely thing to
be practically captured by this now
realistically it's it's unclear um
whether or not these are the kind of
things that are going to um result in uh
the police getting involved necessarily
but the bill also includes uh provision
for protective orders that would allow
third parties um potentially even
campaigning organizations so long as
they can demonstrate uh connection to
the to the family to be able to seek a
court order to um interfere in the
relationship between the parent and
child in that context so practically
speaking what we more likely to see here
is something that we've seen in other
areas of law around this um area which
is that the legislation is relatively
tightly drafted and is intended to
capture very very small sliver of uh
protectional forms of conduct and then
um it's then represented outside of the
legislative legal framework in kind of
society and in um advocacy organizations
as something much more broadly
encompassing than it actually is will
then which will then create a chilling
effect or will will create this kind of
practical problem that causes um people
to modify their behavior even if what
they would have been doing in the past
is not this new criminal offense so
there's a real danger that people um
talking to their family members or their
friends and expressing views like I
don't think it's possible to change
biological sex people might think that
that's being captured by this bill when
in fact it's not the bill specifically
has a carot for that as well so there's
a lot of car outes in this bill um or
this proposal um that will you know it
shows that the Scottish government has
been thinking about the the implications
of this for um potential legal
challenges that they might be facing and
so the actual thing that as Debbie says
that the the bill is trying to do is
extremely narrow um but the the rhetoric
around it and the discussion around it
might make it seem to be much more
broader than it actually is and the
narrow thing that it's doing um is
itself open to Challenge from people who
are of the Viewpoint that you shouldn't
be criminalizing those kinds of
discussions between friends and family
members for example yes Debbie in
Westminster there's been talk in the
past about these conversion therapy bans
but often it's just been seen as too
complicated and terms of legislation in
terms of unintended consequences um
enacting it do you do you think the S&P
government uh thinks it's found a
perfect solution or do you think
something else is driving it in terms of
why they're so focused on this
particularly after the gender
recognition act well you'd think after
they got into so much hot water over the
gender recognition Reform Bill that they
would leave this well alone but uh once
again it seems to the SNP government
trying to uh trying trying to work I
would say outside their remit even in
the in these proposals it talks about
Provisions made for somebody who is
removed from Scotland uh so you can have
a situation where a conversation is
perfectly legal in England but because
somebody is habitually resident in
Scotland and they're taken to England
for that conversation it can then be
illegal in Scotland that that that will
that could become a criminal offense uh
under these proposals and it just seems
to me once again it's that the S&P
government is trying to legislate
outside what uh what is their remit of a
default of a devolved uh Authority yeah
Michael how do you think that will work
because obviously we've previously seen
uh the S&P government fail when it came
to their um as de's mentioning their
last uh big gender recognition policy
and it was challenged by the UK
government successfully is this going to
create any issues like that in the sense
of uh how it works across uh you know
over to England and
Scotland I think there there's less of
of a risk of that with with this bill
partially because um the Scotland act
actually has a number of instances where
we've seen legislation that is um that
looks like it might have a crossb
implication but um but actually doesn't
so the a classic example of this might
be um taxing people on property that
they own in Scotland or taxing people
who are resident on property that they
own outside of Scotland that's been um
that would be kind of understood pretty
clearly as being within the competency
of the Scottish Parliament be able to
legislate on the issue here um is is
kind of twofold and it's more related to
things like um human rights so um things
like the freedom of expression freedom
of religion freedom of belief and
there's an assessment in this proposal
that says that they've considered the
impact that this um proposed legislation
would have on the ability of um people
to express their religious beliefs or to
engage in religious practices or
philosophical beliefs we know that
gender critical feminism is is a is a
protected philosophical belief as well
and the Scottish government has said
that they don't think there's going to
be a significant impact um on the
enjoyment of the rights that people
have and if you look specifically or
strictly at the the bill itself there's
um or the proposals that they have um
they have narrowly tailored this to
ensure that it's only going to be
affecting a
small sliver of conduct but there could
still potentially be human rights
challenges that um occur here and those
challenges that the Scottish Parliament
is not empowered to breach international
human rights obligations under the
European Convention of uh of Human
Rights and so um you you could
potentially see challenges here um as
well and you could also see challenges
in terms of how the proposals are
implemented so it's one thing if on the
books it says that they're not going to
be using this to um criminalize people
expressing their uh their lawfully held
views or they're not going to use it to
crimin ize um therapists engaging in
exploratory therapy with um patients but
if in practice that's what the police
end up doing if in practice you end up
getting a call uh from a police officer
that says look you've not actually
breached the law but you're in real
danger of doing so and I want to warn
you and I'm going to record this as a
hate incident and we've seen this kind
of examples happening in the past um
Scotland is is is in a different
situation to um the United Kingdom as a
whole because Scotland
constitutional framework places very
Express limits on um the legislative
capacity of Scotland I don't think that
this bill would be out with the capacity
of the Scottish Parliament but its
implementation might run into human
rights challenges and Debbie uh just
finally what do you think you know is
there a chance this doesn't become law
we've seen in the past uh when it comes
to the S&P ranks Kate Forbes Ash Reagan
have been questioning of him YF and the
green party in some of the direction
here could we see a bit of push back
potentially well politically it's very
interesting and it's the basis of the
government in Scotland how much this is
being driven by the greens by the
Scottish greens and how much by the S&P
itself is not certain and as the uh NE
as the general election approach is uh
the S&P must be looking at their
knocking on doors and thinking about
their voters and realizing that this
this sort of legislation is not what the
voters are looking for you know there's
far more pressing concerns of the the
people of Scotland have got far more
pressing concerns than what Michael has
described as very very narrow
legislation that uh will pick up very
little thank you Debbie thank you
Michael and finally what is the secret
to a long and happy relationship for the
magazine The Spectators producer Natasha
fose who was producing this week's
episode has written about one couple who
thinks a contract is the answer Simone
and Malcolm Collins authors of the book
a pragmatist guide to relationships are
convincing couples to iron out any
issues in a relationship Manifesto could
it be the answer they join me now Simone
Malcolm thank you for joining spectator
TV today um let's talk about your
relationship contract and Simone can you
tell us how the idea came
about you know I don't really know how
it first came about I think Malcolm and
I started really enjoying hearing
relationship disaster stories when we
were dating um this was even before we
were engaged um and then it led to
conversations of like okay well what
would we do in this situation what would
we do you know if we were married and
our parents were you know elderly and
infirm and they wanted to move into our
house um and then you know after we
discussed these things we're like well
we should I I'm assuming we were
probably like Malcolm you can correct me
you know we decided to write them down
and then we decided to become a lot more
systematic with it so then we we
actively sought it out every possible
way that people ended their
relationships that their relationships
went sour and then made an effort to
pre-negotiate those things before they
became heated Concepts but this was
again well before we were ever engaged
so it's pretty impressive it's important
to remember that every marriage is a
contract and that contractual agreement
differs between cultural groups
expectations of I'm entering you know an
Islamic marriage in the Middle East are
going to be very different than
expectations of
entering a a generic American marriage
versus a a marriage in a more strict
religious culture within America the
problem we have in our society now is
that because we have so many different
cultural groups intermixing and because
cultural norms are shifting every year
two people can enter the contract of a
marriage thinking that they're they're
they're agreeing to the same thing when
they actually are internally agreeing to
two completely different sets of rules
and two completely different internal
contracts and so what we were doing when
we were putting all of this out is being
like let's make sure that both of us
understand what we're really agreeing to
with this marriage and when you started
writing it Malcolm I wondered did you
expect it to be as long as it ended up
being or did you find that uh you know
you you'll think you know oh it's just
these things and convers conversations
would lead to more conversations and
more things to discuss to put in the
contract yeah I I guess I kind of
expected it to be longer um because we
tried to be exhaustive about it we tried
to I mean we went through um and we go
to conferences and we just go table to D
will interview people old people like
what went wrong in your relationship
what went right in your relationship um
we tried to create an exhaustive list of
every conflict we could find that had
ended a relationship or seriously SED a
relationship and it turns out that yeah
while it's long like you know maybe like
10 pages or something like that there
the the the common conflicts kept
recurring um um and there was some stuff
like the one that Simone mentioned that
I hadn't thought to to go through I will
say some things I'm always shocked when
somebody's like married and they're like
you know we just never thought to
discuss whether we wanted kids or not
it's like how that seems like the first
thing you
[Laughter]
discuss um Simone was there anything
when you were going over the contract uh
that surprised you um about Malcolm
things that perhaps um you thought you
might agree on and then you realized oh
we have it we have different
views
yeah and this is actually one of my
favorite things about negotiating a
relationship contract because there are
lots of things that um maybe one partner
may just assume is going to happen by
default but doesn't really care about
and the other partner actually does care
about um and if these things come up
later in a heated kind of context they
could become really toxic for the
relationship so for example I grew up in
a really Progressive Society um and I
just assume that if I got married I'd
never change my last name
um and to Malcolm that was really
important um and I was like well you
know I'm I'm not going to change my last
name um
and to that to him that was a pretty big
deal um and he explained to me exactly
why you know here are the reasons why
you know married couples with the same
last name seem more aligned all these
other reasons um and so I was like oh
yeah this actually doesn't really matter
that much to me and you're actually
quite right um and so we each of us when
negotiated when negotiating our
relationship contract
ended up changing our mind on a lot of
default stances that we had just based
on like the society that we'd grown up
in um so I really appreciated that and
it really allows you to temporarily
trade uh uh sort of um concessions that
normally temporarily you wouldn't be
able to trade so for example if you
don't really care that much about like
naming rights to kids but you really
care about home temperature you can
trade like we get my preference on home
temperature and you get first naming
right on on the kids or something like
that right um but normally these two
things would have like no temporal
relation to each other uh and a lot of
people look at this and they're like
well it's so rigid that you would write
all of this out you know um and I think
that the it's a completely living
document you know we change it every
year um but it it is a list of
expectations so that we understand like
expectation wise what we're going thing
into things with with it and I think I
would really recommend it to everyone
these days what happens if one of you
breaches something in the
contract in the end like so you can set
any any any couple can set whatever
stipulations they have for rule breaking
and each different violation can have a
different you know punishment for
example like if you violate your agreed
upon internal home temperature you know
that's not going to be the same as if
like somebody um commits infidelity uh
as defined in the contract right so um
for us it's honestly just like it's it's
going to hurt my feelings it's going to
make me less happy in this relationship
and it's obvious that if enough things
happen where that's the case that
probably that person is going to end the
relationship but the big thing that we
don't have is if you do this for example
like if you cheat I leave you because
typically what happens when that happens
in a relationship is somebody cheats and
it was assumed that they would then be
left if they got found but nobody leaves
and then they're sort of everything else
falls apart all other expectations fall
apart because oh wait so now all the
other rules do they not get punished
either like is this kind of you know
what what matters anymore um so it's
really important to only have
punishments or penalties that will
always be followed through and frankly
if you're in a loving relationship and
you care about the relationship
continuing um just being sad or having
your feelings hurts kind of one of the
most practical things to have there and
I can't help but ask what is your agreed
home temperature as per the
contract it's so it used to be
68° um now it is uh 58° at night uh in
one part of the house um and it's 50
degrees uh in the rest of the house
because it's really expensive to heat
our old farmhouse here and we just
bundle up um just a few final things I
wondered have you had you know friends
people you've met have started doing
these relationship contracts um because
you've spoken about it you have would
you encourage others to do it what would
your advice be so we wrote a bestselling
book called The pragmatist guide to
relationships and we also do a podcast
called based camp where we often talk
about this stuff so these ideas have
gained some popularity um and uh
everyone I think who engages With It
ultimately appreciates it a lot of
cultural groups uh have sort of
alternatives to this so if you look at
like Catholic relationships that they
have like before you get married you're
supposed to go and have like marriage
counseling with the church and this is a
useful thing to have but as more and
more people have moved back from these
more traditional structures and cultures
they don't have these evoked sanity
checks on marriage and the relationship
contract more than anything rather than
it being a set of rules I think a person
can think of it as a sanity check on you
deciding to get married to someone as an
alternative to you know go seeing you
know a local priest or local
psychologist or something like that
before getting married um because it it
still allows total self- ownership
there's a lot of interesting stuff in
the one of the things that we always say
about marriage is the the death of
marriages is compromis um and this is
the problem because a lot of people go
into marriage expecting well if we ever
have a disagreement then we'll just
compromise the problem with compromise
when you have disagreements is if one
party wants you know one and the other
party wants eight uh just I'm just
giving some arbitrary value vales here
then U even subconsciously they're
rewarded for exaggerating their
positions you know the person who wants
one is subconsciously rewarded for
pretending they want zero the person who
wants eight is subconsciously rewarded
for pretending they want more than that
and this leads to a situation in which
wherever the couple uh has any sort of
difference they begin to psychologically
drift to even more extreme positions
than they came into the relationship
with uh due to this subconscious reward
mechanism um and so one of the things
that's really important to outline in
the relationship contract is not just
the expectations but how disputes are
resolved um because right now in society
we don't have a a real expectation for
how marital disputes are solved outside
of well some sort of vague compromise or
whoever appears to emotionally care
about the issue more but then if you
create the well whoever emotionally
cares about the issue more is decide
that we default to then that means that
there is a subconscious reward for these
huge emotional displays whenever an
issue comes up um but instead you can
build systems where like well everything
tied to like home finances one person is
in charge of everything tied to you know
X another person is in charge of um or
you can put all of the the
responsibility on a single partner which
is what we do in our relationship
contract um which actually often leads
to and a lot of people are surprised of
this but a lot of people who've gone
into and used our system have found that
this works the person who actually makes
the ultimate decision if you give the
control complet completely to them
usually makes decisions which a on the
side of preferencing the other person
because they have gratitude for this
level of uh autonomy that was sacrificed
to them and that's something that just
as Society we don't really have an
evoked set for anymore but it is the way
a lot of relationships used to be
structured and just finally I wondered
um Simone if you think about I suppose
the alternative which is perhaps um more
a stereotypically British approach of
not having awkward conversations and
being very polite um some would argue
perhaps uh you know uh sources close to
myself that there's quite a nice
surprise in a marriage in a way of not
knowing where you stand on everything
you as you as you go on the journey you
find more things out I mean what what
would you say to that school of thought
I would say that's that's how marriages
end up in unhappiness abuse divorce um
this is like the worst possible thing
you could do there are very very rarely
um unexpected surprises um it's almost
always unexpected disappointments like
oh wait I thought we were going to have
four kids and my wife wants to have one
or none or oh wait I thought my husband
was going to help out around the house
but he expects me to do absolutely
everything um so these things just i'
I've never really heard of them become
unexpected surprises we did this
specifically because we really wanted
our marriage to last
and now we're not saying everyone has to
like do what we did and make a Google
doc with revision history where we
negotiate every single point um though a
lot of our friends have taken like our
template document that we created and
you know run with it and used it at
least as a jumping off point for
conversations but a lot of people do
just have conversations about these
things and that's for example what many
Church counselors do for couples before
they get married this is really common
in the Catholic Church um where they
will just walk they will walk you
through it they'll be like well what
number of kids do you expect to have and
then you you have to have that hard
conversation um and we just our view
with relationships is if it's going to
end let it end now so you can find the
right person sooner don't waste five 10
who knows how many years on somebody who
isn't ultimately going to help you live
the life that you really really want to
live you know you need to you need to
move on quickly a breakup is a good
thing especially if it happens
early thanks thank you malcol thank you
Simone that's it for this week once
again if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of the video tap the Bell icon
and you will never miss an episode again
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next
[Music]
week